yeah so it just like works look at how
fast you're going good job
hey girls hungry someone's making a dank
Instagram story yes it's a story about a
grown woman at the theater
yes
[Music]
please enjoy a brief intermission there
dude
does your I stink whoo yeah stinks
let's go holy Ilana it smells like
for shoot you cannot go to the Divakar
shoot like this you got to go to a
doctor right away and get this cleared
up for the family honor doctor I don't
have a doctor here you don't have a
doctor here no one in this city does
that's why it's a cesspool
all right it's an emergency go to the
emergency room go to st. Vincent's it's
condos sorry so Cabrini also kind of how
about that what's his name dr. on
Houston Street it's not kind of but it's
a Whole Foods again why do you love this
city you gotta get an ambulance dude you
smell like a dog's ass what you say a
dog's ass dog's ass okay do I know who
can cure me I got this oh I hope so
[Music]
hey can you drive me downtown and just
weave in and out of traffic very fat
listen I'm not a petty cab driver I'm a
real estate broker read the sign okay
then why do you have a pedicab that's
the fastest way to get clients to
apartments for multiple viewings you
know I think I know you are you a cop
no but you showed my friend and I an
apartment years ago a bunch of shitty
apartments I mean they were all literal
crime scenes crime scene homes are my
specialty
you know I got a mix that works at the
NYPD helps me up I just get my hand job
once in a while okay since mystery this
is a modeling emergency well well well
is Lee one of these babies could have
been yours waiting is terrible in here
shenanigans
Oh somebody hey Abby its Leslie
hey hey what's up girl
okay I'm sorry I have to go before you
on the model the doctors with a patient
yeah I'm a model stop doctor oh sorry
Ilana I told you I cannot spay - neuter
a human and it is not reversible no I I
googled that you were right about it I'm
here about this oh okay
that looks bad have a seat okay good
girl
good good well I actually wanted to
apologize to you for before oh yeah yeah
oh you see my Instagram what yeah never
mind what what's that look the truth is
I'm really set in my ways and maybe I'm
self sabotaging this whole thing because
I have a lot of fun with you shenanigans
and all figuring it out well
well things I mean thank you for saying
that I you really hurt my feelings this
morning do you think there's any way
that we could try this again
you mean like get back together yes I
think you're crazy what are you uh we
done tonight well I think I may have a
date with my very adult very sexy artist
girlfriends yeah - hey before we lock in
any logistics all right um got myself in
a little trouble I did need I do need
you to collude one one what you picked
under it's totally on you I'm cool with
whatever
Jesus Christ Abbi
[Music]